My name is Jessi Dyer,
and I work here at L.L.Bean.
L.L.Bean was founded in 1912
by an avid outdoorsman,
Leon Leonwood Bean.
His first creation was
the Maine hunting shoe.
That boot, most commonly
known as the L.L.Bean boot,
is our most iconic product.
And we've made this for 110 years.
If a customer has a
pair of well-worn boots
and is not ready to give them up,
we can easily resole them
and bring them back to like-new condition.
In order to replace and
put a new bottom on it,
we will be removing the
upper from this boot.
It will go in the saw,
and we will start detaching
that with the saw and a blade.
The boots get clamped,
they get put into the saw,
and it cuts right down through
the bottom of the boot.
Once the boot comes out of the machine,
it does have a piece of the brush guard
that is still attached to the leather.
We remove this in order to have
the leather all nice and clean,
so that it can fit on the new bottom,
snug and complete.
We call this "stripping the boot."
We use a flat knife as well as scissors
to cut the stitches away from the upper.
Once this happens, we can handpick
all of the stitches that remain behind.
In order to help us get
these stitches out easier,
we actually have a rub machine,
and this is very much
like a rotating bristle.
The outside of the leather boot
actually brushes up against that,
and it helps loosen the stitches
so that we can pull them out easier
and have a nice, clean
finish to the leather upper.
We then pick out all of the threads
from the bottom part of the upper
so that it can be restitched
onto the new bottom nice and clean
and not have any straggling
pieces of thread left behind.
We're now going to start reassembly.
In this step, we are actually going to
remove the old heel protector
and attach a new one.
This particular boot is
looking for a brand-new bottom.
So we were replacing it
with the exact same bottom
that the customer received
when they purchased the boot originally.
In order for this to properly attach,
we make sure that there
is any dust or debris
or stitches that are all removed.
Once that happens, we
actually apply cement
to both the new bottom boot
as well as the leather upper.
Once that is complete,
we move right on to the vamping process.
We have a vamping machine that we've done,
and this is all done by hand.
So this particular machine will drop
three needles down into
the boot with stitches
and complete the stitching
process to the boot bottom.
We use great care to line up the holes.
At times, this requires
slowing down the machine
and really taking a fine look
as to where those holes are.
Once we complete the vamp,
we move over to the packing station.
Here is where we will
give it one final look
to make sure that quality is ensured.
Before boxing, we make sure
that we are wiping down
any debris that could be left behind.
We replace the lace and the inner sole
on each boot, just due to wear.
We try to get everything
right back to its original status.
Now that the boots are complete,
we go to packing them
up and shipping them out
to another happy customer.
I'm really happy at how
these boots came out,
and I cannot wait for
our customer to see them.